[Music]
the division 2 is almost here and those
of you who played the beta will probably
already know that several things feel
similar to the division 1 that said
there are a few really interesting new
features that we discovered from the
beta which are primed to spice things up
this time around it may be the post
apocalypse but that doesn't mean there
aren't plenty of survivors and ways to
help them in the division - this is
emphasized through settlements
settlements include plenty of NPCs who
need your help opportunities for side
quests and projects to undertake which
will grant you with blueprints and other
goodies if you can rustle up certain
supplies and bring them back settlements
also offer up new traders and
recruitable NPCs for the White House
base which provides access to new items
and perks the inclusion of projects also
makes chasing collectables feel more
rewarding not to mention the warm
fuzzies from everyone telling you you're
awesome when you bolster your
settlements and White House headquarters
[Music]
there's enough of an endgame revamp in
the division to that you really need to
check out our in-depth preview innocence
though the game has been developed with
endgame in mind from the very beginning
the hallmarks of the experience are the
new high ranking specializations that
come with power weapons and invaded
missions which feature the same mission
areas as earlier in the game but they're
now occupied by a brutally tough new
faction called the black tusk
this comes hand-in-hand with the new
occupied dark zone an area under black
tusk occupation that ignores level
balancing and friendly fire handicaps
but has great rewards for those who can
handle it characters are also far more
personalized and customizable this time
around with multiple types for each
gadget plenty of mods and an overall
deeper skill set
much like the endgame there's a lot of
new bits and pieces to check out in the
dark zone but one of the most welcomed
changes is that you don't feel like
you've wasted time if you're killed off
at loot extraction as division 1 players
can attest nothing is worse than sinking
an hour into the dark zone only to lose
your loot at the last second now you can
pick up uncontaminated loot which you'll
be able to keep and use without having
to extract it first contaminated loot
can still be found and extracted but it
will be reserved for rarer gear on top
of that there are new rewards for those
who are keen to go rogue as you'll open
up access to unique vendors throughout
the dark zone
while I personally enjoyed the concrete
jungle of New York City there's a lot to
be said for the shift over to Washington
there are more varied environments than
before not to mention both greenery and
critters like deer and raccoons running
amuck the bay that didn't provide access
to the entire map but what we've seen so
far is promising patrolling friendlies
add a new element to open world
exploration maintaining ownership of
control points scattered around the
capital opens up access to supply rooms
full of loot and having the White House
as your base of operations to defend and
rebuild is just super cool there's also
a greater focus on visiting landmarks
and even a mission to steal the
Declaration of Independence
so you're basically Nic Cage
one of the more frustrating aspects of
the division was the damn near
bulletproof enemies who you had to chip
away at to take down the division to
addresses the bullet sponge complaints
in a pretty interesting way weaker
enemies are fairly squishy and easy to
take down
while tougher foes have armor you'll
need to target before you go in for the
kill this means you'll want to be more
strategic about where you hit tough
enemies but once that armor is gone they
go down faster will you still be
emptying entire clips onto elite enemies
shop but at least you can see the fruits
of your labor this time around let me
know which of the division choose new
features you're most excited about down
in that comment box and stay tuned to
gave us what for the rest of our
coverage